stop trying to change people stop trying
to change people into something that
they're not and instead bring on people
who are the people that you need it's a
way better way to build your business
here's an example so I I recently hired
an artist okay I wanted to create some
art around thinking big I've got this
new guide coming out on my website to
help entrepreneurs think big and land
bigger deal stop struggling with the
crappy tiny deals and land something big
for your business and I wanted a piece
of art to go across the top of my page
that spoke to the feeling of thinking
big I was looking to the artist for
guidance you know like I don't know how
to create this art that's why I'm coming
at you here's the feeling I want make me
something that makes me think big and
feel inspired to think big that's what
I'm hiring you for and I search for
artists and I I went up and down and I
found an artist who I really I liked her
work I liked what she had created I like
the the her approach I like the realism
I liked what she had made and I hired
her to create this piece of art it was
okay it was good it was realistic it was
a style that I wanted but she didn't
capture the feeling she didn't make me
want to think big through this picture
that was the whole point it was a
beautiful picture but it didn't have the
feeling and that the art doesn't have
feeling it's useless I needed it to have
the feeling and so I went back and forth
and said I need this I need this to have
the feeling better I need this for I
love it I love the work you did it's
it's great it looks beautiful but I
don't get the feeling of thinking bigger
from this and I don't know what to do to
add to it to to make this better
and I spoke with Jason who's on my team
and it's adjacent I you know I don't
know maybe you can help maybe you can
maybe you can lend some guidance here
and maybe you want to talk to her I
don't know and he he reminded me of
something that I knew but but I wasn't
applying and it's very helpful and he
said we can try to make this work you
know we can we can try to talk to her
try to give some instruction but you're
you're trying to pull out something from
her that isn't there it's not part of
her that's not what she's all about she
creates other kind of art you need
somebody who understands that feeling of
thinking big and can create it for you
and he was right he's right because no
matter how much I try to tell her she
doesn't get the feeling that I'm after
and this applies to any anybody that you
hire if they can't understand what
you're doing there's some things that
could be trained and saying do this
follow these procedures but other things
they have it's part of them it's what
they believe in it's their values
it's how they see the world you can't
change that you shouldn't try to change
that and as entrepreneurs we do try to
change that because it's so painful and
hard to get somebody else so I have
somebody here why can't they do their
job why can't they be what I want them
to be and some amount of training can
help but if you're talking about
changing mindset and changing
personality and changing outlook on life
that is super hard to change and instead
of changing somebody into somebody
they're not you should go out and find
someone who's already that because both
people will be happy the person who who
is not who you need who you're trying to
force and change they're not happy right
now working for you they're frustrated
that they can't get what you want them
to do so let them be free and find
somewhere where they can fit in better
and you'll be much happier and less
stressed out and see better results if
you bring on the right person who sees
the world the way you need them to see
the world so I need to go out and do all
the hard work again now finding the
right artist so if you guys know an
artist who can think big and you can
capture that in the picture let me know
but for now stop trying to change people
into people they aren't and focus on
finding the people who are exactly who
you need for your business belief who
those are watching like the video give
it a thumbs up I love them coming in
thank you so much leave a comment to let
me know what you think leave your
thoughts below your comments inspire me
to do more videos for you I really
appreciate them you have a question
leave a
I'm making a video response thank you so
much and I'll see you soon